So, I want to know, what do you understand by
a distributed system and I am going to give you three
choices, nice perfectly fine if you don't get it right
but I just wanted to get you thinking in terms of
what a distributed system is and what your understanding is.
The first choice says that a distributed system is a collection
of Nodes connected by a Local Area Network or a
Wide Area Network. Second choice says that, a distributed system is
one in which communication happens only via messages. And
the third choice is that, a distributed system is
one in which events that are happening on the
same node, here like A and B. The time
between that is called the event time. And the
event that is happening across nodes, which is a
communication event, Node N1 sends a message to node
N2, it's a communciation event from A to C. So,
the third choice is saying that communication time
TM, is much more Significantly more than the event
execution time. That is the third choice so
you have three choices and I want you to
think about what's your definition, what's your mental
model of distributed system is and how any of
these choices fit or do not fit your mental
model of what you think a distributed system is.